lorsque je suis arrivé sur le site web
de bons fournisseurs d'accès à internet
je suis tombé sur une nouvelle jolie
il s'agissait d'une nouvelle relative à
une coutume dans l'état you can donc
cesser nord-ouest du canada si je situe
bien dans la petite ville de dawson city
l'hôtel banton a une particularité qui
est vraiment il dirait renversante
séquelles vous permet pour chaque dollar
canadien de boire d'alcool et dans le
flacon lien l'orteil humain vous aviez
cette question mais d'où viendra donc
cet orteil à l'origine on avait eu une
seule tout commence par une belle une
belle orteils ça commence en 1920
quelque part dans les années 1920 et pas
de date précise plus que ça mais à
l'origine il ya un trappeur et un
coureur de rome c'est à dire quelqu'un
qui agi légalement qui fait le commerce
du rhum en traîneau en plein hiver il
s'appelle louis deacon
il est avec son son frère et il y arrive
une mésaventure et il plonge son pied
dans un dans un ruisseau mouillé et
évidemment en plein hiver c'est très
dangereux est il sage elle sait on a
parlé ici d'une engelures au point où la
seule façon de remédier au problème
c'est de couper leur taille pouf
comment savoir la faire d'ici monsieur
lesquels louis demande à son frère au
taux de lui couper donc leur tête avec
une hache plutôt que de se rendre à
l'hôpital
les deux frères craint que la grc la
gendarmerie royale du canada soit sur
leurs pas et et ils vont placer le bout
d'orteil dans une des bouteilles de rhum
pour le préserver je ne sais trop
pourquoi
c'est ça lui apparemment ils ont bu
beaucoup avant de couper leur taille les
avez peur d'avoir mal
alors ils ont eu une quantité massive
dit on de rome est bon
bout de leur taille s'est retrouvé comme
ça dans une bouteille et c'est arrivé à
dawson city
on ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé entre
1920 et quelques et 1973
au moment où le propriétaire du yu
combat requis c'est un homme qui
s'appelait dick stevenson trouve impôts
qui contenait leur paye il est en train
de nettoyer une petit entrepôt et là
l'idée que lui vient pourquoi pas
plonger ça dans le whisky
on va appeler ça le sartre au cocktail
on va même forme et inclut pourquoi pas
et l'idée l'idée prend racine pendant
sept ans les gens vont on se présenter
pour passer le test du sarto et le test
est le suivant vous devez d'en consommer
votre verre dans lesquelles se trouvent
leur taille le bout d'orteil vous devez
le toucher du bout des lèvres mais sans
jamais la vallée parce que si vous la
vallée la mort d'aujourd'hui c'est 500 $
je ne sais pas c'était quoi en 1973 mais
c'est une amende salée pour ce produit
qui est sûrement un petit peu sucré et
le bar se retrouve avec une pénurie
d'orteils il ya quelques temps les
quelques années à peine
ils ont été obligés de placer des
petites annonces des journaux de
l'endroit où de la région et aussi sur
leur site web le site web du bar du
yukon du centre-ville de ce village en
disant on est à la recherche de
d'orteils de bout d'orteil si vous en
avez laisse nous le savoir on serait
intéressé à en faire l'acquisition
et là dans la dent l'annoncent ont
mentionné le fait qu'ils nous il leur
restait seulement sous la main eu un
pied un pied gauche est passée les
orteils du pied gauche il ya le puits
quoi soutenir donc la demande des
consommateurs pour le sahara tôt et ils
ont eu des offres d'arles des fois c'est
pas une bombe seulement des gens qui ont
des engelures
mais des gens qui ont des accidents de
chasse et il ya des gens qui offrent
comme ça
généreusement il faut dire que quand
vous faites un don vous vous retrouvez
votre nom dans ce qu'ils appellent le
sartre au hall of fame donc dans le
grand livre des registres de lille nous
a laissé l'image des donneurs en tout
temps on a interviewé si je pense que
c'est un réseau d'intelligence
américains qui faisaient la ronde qui se
tenait bon qu'est ce qu'ils font les
canadiens ils mettent des orteils dans
leur whisky il ya docteur robert truands
qui est un spécialiste au centre
hospitalier de cleveland aux états unis
qui a déclaré que non le seul danger
c'était l'étouffement
c'est le seul tout mais dix citations
ici consommer leur taille n'aurait aucun
effet mauvais temps qu'il est bien
conservé et vidé de tout son sens et
aussi des fluides corporels et qu'il ait
conservé suffisamment longtemps pour
sécher il n'y a donc pas un moyen pour
les maladies infectieuses comme
l'hépatite ou le vih d'exister dans cet
orteil dans le whisky
[Musique]
ça aide un peu sa pole on prendre un
verre à votre santé on ne vous oubliera
jamais merci beaucoup nous avons
contacté puis à la prochaine pour une
prochaine discussion
[Musique]